foreign
Idaho what's up Kyle
ah not too much how are you John I'm
doing good man not too much not too much
what's up man
um so
um just quick question of
kind of
I've been with this girl for about three
years
um I don't know if I should leave
um
it's been
it's been good but
it's wanna sorry I'm nervous it's like
it's been fine
[Laughter]
though he has
um he has mental and physical health
problems okay I've always been there for
them and
I I've never had a problem with any of
that
but over the last year or so she's been
very controlling
to a point where I'm not allowed to go
see my family until she can see her
family and we all both of our families
live in different states
so it's kind of hard to see either one
of them but
we try to make it out whenever we can
um it also goes as far as I'm not
allowed to hang out with friends because
she doesn't have her family or her
friends in the state
[Music]
that's hard man I'm sorry
um
are y'all married
uh we are not we've been dating for
three years okay
the easy flippant answer for me is this
the purpose of dating is get to know
somebody
and get to practice safety and get to
practice compatibility get to practice
intimacy
and over the last 36 months you have
come to realize I don't want this life
I don't want somebody who a is going to
be so utterly controlling in a way that
makes it no logical or rational sense
right this is different if you call me
and be like I just want to go to the bar
do we only go four nights a week and she
wants me home with her I would say
you're you're a right that's not
the case here right this is no this is
um this is power and control
the other side of the coin here is if
you've got somebody who you love who's
struggling with mental health issues and
physical issues and is not doing
everything they can in their power to go
get well to do the things they need to
do to be whole
okay then they're ultimately making a
choice for the type of relationship they
want to have so let me take anxiety for
example I'm never gonna blame anybody
for having anxiety that's your body's
response is trying to take care of you
right and anxiety looks like all
different kinds of things to all
different kind of people
but I will hold you accountable for
going to get the help you need
yeah see what I'm saying and so yeah if
I step back and I I'm pretty this will
sound really cold okay but if I step
back you're in relationship with
somebody
who um
has
doesn't appear to be interested in doing
the hard hard work
to be as well as possible
and who is more interested in
slowly exerting more and more power to
control over the one person
in her geographical area that's trying
to love her and take care of her
right
so um what does it look like if you if
you broke up
so let's do that thought added on to
that I I don't want to be morbid about
this by any means but we have a the only
loan I have and I'm trying to get rid of
but we have an auto loan in both of our
names
um I am primary on it um how much is 30
000.
sell the car dude
but
my thing is she doesn't want to sell it
she's the another thing that we disagree
about is our spending and
but I want to sell it I want to get
basically I'm all in on the Ramsay thing
where I want to get out of debt I don't
like owing people money yeah in general
I don't either so yeah so here's the
thing man don't let this is a
to quote quote Jocko this is this is a
non-factor
okay okay give her the car and pay it
off and
um to quote Dave Ramsey it's just a
thirty thousand dollar stupid tax
mm-hmm oh man I got an auto loan with a
girlfriend that was dumb
right and I put both of our name on the
title I was dumb
that's all right
30 000 bucks
okay it's less expensive than a divorce
three years from now
true right
ultimately ultimately here's the deal
I'm not gonna tell you to leave I'm not
gonna take a breakup I'm not gonna tell
you doing those things what I am going
to tell you is you get to decide what
your life looks like
right and you get to decide beyond what
it looks like in terms of the size of
the house or size of car or something
like that you get to decide the
the warmth and the air inside of your
home is it electric and charged and
chaotic or is coming home a place of
Peace both you and the person you mayor
get to choose that
and we get so lost with our Diagnostics
and our this is and I've got this and
this happened to me cool
I get to walk in my front door and
decide how this place is going to be
and I'm gonna work every plan I can come
up with I'm gonna do everything I can
to create that space then you look at
the person you're thinking about
marrying and saying well you create that
space with me
and the hard part is what you're telling
me is she has said no I'm good
I'm gonna do what I want to do when I
want to do it and by the way so are
freaking you you are too
a little bit but or a lot or a lot
you're saying that it makes me think
that I do come home and have to walk on
eggshells a lot at your houses after
your house
so it's your house I wish more people
would reverse engineer their life in
that way
because
um not owing anybody any money that's a
big deal for me that sets off a lot of
childhood triggers with money issues
growing up
um not owing anybody any money when I
walk in the front door there's never
going to be a bill on my kitchen table
that uh
sends me off into the woods right this
sends my that my 10 year old self has to
come out and try to sword fight and
defend for me
it's never gonna be there I don't need
anybody money and so the for me the
reason I don't owe anybody any money is
so I can walk in my house and drop my
shoulders I'm home
the reason I go to marriage counseling
the reason I go to counseling the reason
I am constantly trying to become a
better dad is I want to walk home and I
can't wait to to meet my kids because my
wife and I have worked really hard to
create to create an environment where we
like our kids and they like being around
us right you see what I'm saying all
this comes back to
I just want to walk in and drop my
shoulders I can do that in a
1400 square foot house and I can do that
in a 2500 square foot house or whatever
like this the particulars for me matter
less than
I just want to start for peace and I
want to solve for freedom and I want to
solve for
[Music]
the same with clutter that same stuff
with crazy filled calendars all that
stuff works together
and so ask yourself
after three years of being together
like she seems to be pretty clear on the
kind of life she wants to have which is
whatever she wants whenever she wants it
okay come come hell or high water come
anxiety come come stress come
frustration come fight come a sad
frustrated uh spouse none of that
matters I get what I want when I want it
[Music]
I miss telling you brother you are worth
peace
thank you
and now it's just up to you man I I know
I'm being Cavalier here and almost
almost clinical it's kind of cold
I understand how hard the decisions you
have to make moving forward are I get
that
very very tough very tough
it's not like you're just going to waltz
in today and be like all right we're
breaking up you have a great one I know
it's way more complex than that and
it's way way more complex
so I'm not gonna tell you to go do that
I'm gonna tell you is
seek peace
seek freedom
seek
a life when after you're out slaying
dragons all day and you're working your
butt off at your job
trying to navigate this Wackadoo culture
we have
I got one safe place
and then you look at that person you're
going to marry and say will you create a
safe place with me
and now you're talking
that's Legacy changing my friend thanks
for the call Kyle